[Música]
en medio de otro nuevo récord de casos
globales diarios con 378 mil positivos
en 24 horas países europeos ajustan sus
medidas y maximizan sus alertas en las
ciudades con más contagios en francia el
primer ministro no descarta con fira
mitos locales y el reino unido están a
la espera del anuncio de nuevas
restricciones por parte de evolución son
pende de un hilo el cese del fuego
acordado entre armenios y hacer y es que
se siguen acusando de ataques que rompen
la tregua en torno al enclave
separatista de nagorno karabaj en vigor
desde el sábado en moscú avanzan los
diálogos para disminuir las tensiones
donald trump retoma sus actos de campaña
este lunes en florida tras asegurar que
ahora es inmune al hobbit 19 una
información considerada engañosa por la
red social 'twitter'
hoy también inician en washington las
audiencias con miras a la confirmación
de la jueza y miconi barrett a la corte
suprema lo que augura nuevos
enfrentamientos entre republicanos y
demócratas analizamos en esta emisión
hola cómo están bienvenidos de vuelta
aquí a las noticias de france 24 mi
nombre es alan austria empezamos en
europa porque francia se está
enfrentando a una fuerte segunda ola de
contagios por kobe 19 esto dijo el
primer ministro del país ya castex por
lo que no descarta aplicar
confinamientos a nivel local tras el
aumento de el coronavirus los
comentarios de castex se produjeron
cuando toulouse y montpellier se unieron
a parís marsella y otras cuatro ciudades
en estado de alerta máxima para combatir
la pandemia y es que los casos de kobe
19 en francia alcanzaron niveles récord
con casi 27.000 positivos en un día
durante el fin de semana la presión
comienza a sentirse de nuevo en los
hospitales del país con la llegada de
los pacientes yo respondo que el ojo
como digo primero que todo que un nuevo
confinamiento general debe ser evitado
por todos los medios es posible si todo
el mundo se compromete
esta semana habrá como siempre un
consejo de defensa veremos qué nos dicen
los datos epidemiológicos al inicio de
la semana y determinaremos si hay razón
para ir más allá
les recuerdo que ya hemos puesto a las
ciudades de montpellier y toulouse en
alerta máquina así que hay que ver qué
datos salen de esas localidades
colectivos y los confinamientos locales
no están excluidos ya nada debe ser
excluido especialmente cuando vemos la
situación de nuestros hospitales de uso
mientras que reino unido está a la
espera del anuncio del primer ministro
británico boris johnson en el que
informaría un sistema de escalonado de
nuevas restricciones en distintas zonas
para contener la propagación oficiales
de salud informaron que el número de
pacientes con kobe 19 en los hospitales
está aumentando rápidamente en el norte
de inglaterra y podría superar el ritmo
visto durante la primera ola los
legisladores votarán las nuevas medidas
a lo largo de la semana que incluyen el
cierre de bares gimnasios y casinos en
las zonas de nivel de alerta muy alto y
el gobierno italiano también está
alistando nuevas restricciones a nivel
nacional que incluyen la prohibición de
fiestas privadas
el viernes italia superó los 5 mil casos
nuevos en un solo día por primera vez
desde marzo los contagios diarios
siguieron por encima de ésta
el sábado y el domingo
nos vamos a iraníes que por segundo día
consecutivo el país anunció su mayor
número de muertos por corona virus en un
solo día este lunes con 272
fallecimientos confirmados la gran
mayoría de las provincias se encuentran
en estado rojo el de máxima propagación
de la enfermedad aunque las que más
preocupan son teherán y qom por la
saturación de las hospitalizaciones en
teherán es obligatorio el uso de
mascarilla en exteriores y hay cierres
temporales de ciertas actividades
económicas culturales y religiosas
los hallazgos de la agencia científica
nacional de australia sugieren que el
kobe 19 podría ser más robusto de lo
previamente pensado ya que podría
sobrevivir durante 28 días en distintas
superficies como plástico o acero en
ciertas condiciones específicas sin
embargo su resistencia disminuye a
medida que aumenta la temperatura nos
informa más abajo
el nuevo coronavirus parece ser bastante
resistente cuando se trata de sobrevivir
en distintos lugares así lo demostró la
agencia científica australiana así es
según la cual el virus responsable del
cobi 19 permanece hasta 28 días en
superficies lisas como pantallas
telefónicas de vidrio acero y billetes
de polímero a una temperatura de 20
grados
cuando aumentamos la temperatura la
supervivencia del virus a corto
ciertamente hasta los 40 grados el virus
sobrevivió generalmente menos de 24
horas así que de cara al verano este va
a ser un factor importante
en comparación con estudios anteriores
que mostraban que el coronavirus podía
sobrevivir hasta cuatro días en
superficies no porosas esto es
significativamente más largo pero estos
resultados son válidos en condiciones de
laboratorio
por ejemplo el experimento se llevó a
cabo en la oscuridad cuando ya se ha
demostrado que la luz ultravioleta mata
el virus
[Música]
en el mundo real esas superficies
probablemente estarán en contacto con
luz solar
[Música]
también estarán en diferentes humedades
diferentes temperaturas por lo tanto en
el mundo real los resultados
probablemente serán más cortos de lo que
pudimos demostrar
aunque el virus pueda sobrevivir por más
de lo pensado no se sabe a ciencia
cierta hasta qué punto puede generar
nuevas infecciones las principales vías
de contagio siguen siendo las gotículas
expulsadas por las personas al toser o
estornudar los expertos se esperan que
el estudio ayude a desarrollar nuevas
estrategias de mitigación continúan las
acusaciones mútuas de nuevos ataques
entre armenios y azeríes en torno al
enclave separatista de nagorno karabaj
donde entró en vigor un cese del fuego
que parece cada vez más frágil
azerbayán denunció ataques contra sus
posiciones militares durante la noche
mientras que desde en ago no cara baja
hablaron también de arremetidas
militares a series en la localidad hacer
y de sant que se llevaron a cabo las
honras fúnebres de varias víctimas
civiles que perdieron la vida durante
los ataques registrados en granja la
segunda ciudad más grande de azerbayán
tanto avanzan en moscú los diálogos con
miras a sostener el cese de hostilidades
el ministro armenio de asuntos
exteriores sobre matsa khanjian pidió un
mecanismo de verificación del alto el
fuego humanitario rusia pide que se
respete lo pactado
se logró un importante acuerdo con la
iniciativa del presidente putin
puig
hasta ahora hemos visto que dicho pacto
no se ha cumplido a cabalidad la
actividad militar continúa
esperamos que la comunicación que
mantenemos con ustedes y con nuestros
vecinos a series sobre mí incluyendo los
ministros de defensa logre el
cumplimiento de los acuerdos
trilaterales
hoy empiezan las audiencias con miras a
la confirmación de la jueza emi con
ibarreta a la corte de suprema de eeuu
en reemplazo de la fallecida ruth báder
ginsburg en ocasiones anteriores este
proceso ha tomado regularmente más de
dos meses sin embargo los republicanos
pretenden ejecutarlo antes de las
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre
teniendo una derrota del presidente de
trump es por ello que lanzamos con
celina romaní y es constitucionalista
muchas gracias por esta comunicación
abogada los demócratas se enfocan en las
amenazas que un tribunal conservador de
6-3 podría plantear a la ley de cuidado
de salud asequible y a los derechos al
aborto que tan tensas se esperan las
audiencias
bueno yo creo que una de las cosas más
importantes como acaba de señalar es el
hecho de que se están dando un contexto
que no tiene precedentes cuando todos en
este momento toda la población está
votando muchas de la pobla están votando
por adelantado o sea que el mandato que
se supone que sea que un presidente
puede
y nombrar a una y nominar a una juez o
un juez del tribunal supremo y refleja
que tiene el apoyo de el pueblo en este
momento eso está incierto pero yo me
imagino que los demócratas tratarán de
evitar hablar sobre los dichos de
religión en donde se ha atacado mucho
que ella es una católica ferviente pero
también muy conservadora dentro del
catolicismo y yo me imagino que eso es
parte de lo que van a tratar de evitar y
más concentrarse en la filosofía
judicial de ella que es una filosofía
conservadora ella fue ayudante del
pasado huesca lía del difunto huesca lía
que tiene una visión de que la
constitución tiene que interpretarse de
una forma original que no se tiene que
adaptar que no es una constitución viva
que se adapta a los cambios sociales a
los cambios
culturales de una nación y también es
recordar y yo me imagino que se lo van a
recordar que la constitución es parte
de un andamiaje de protección a los
derechos de los individuos y las
minorías cuando las mayorías a través de
las leyes
legislan y violan y vulneran derechos de
los de las minorías pues para el ph está
el tribunal así que no parece que se van
a concentrar más en la filosofía
judicial porque políticamente no creo
que es una buena idea concentrar que la
realidad soy abogada y tienen los
demócratas alguna posibilidad de detener
la confirmación si no pueden hacerlo qué
opinión le merece la posibilidad de
agregar nuevos escaños a la corte
suprema y es que esto ya parece una
posibilidad si los demócratas toman el
control
o sea esto es una posibilidad que se
está planteando nadie
lasexta todavía porque dicen que es muy
prematuro y además yo creo que pudiera
también afectar en el electorado las
elecciones y por eso el candidato vaivén
y la propia candidata a vicepresidente
presidencial canadá a alice no han
querido abundar sobre esto pero esto es
una estrategia que pudiera realmente
tener a su disposición del partido
demócrata si gana y obtiene la mayoría
en el senado porque esta sería la
primera vez con el nombramiento de esta
vuelta que se consolida de una manera
significativa una visión conservadora de
la constitución y una visión
conservadora de cuál es el rol del
tribunal supremo de eeuu y de atrás en
muchos de los derechos que se han
logrado reconocer por ese mismo tribunal
muy bien abogada pues muchas gracias por
esta comunicación ella es el inah román
y constitucionalista y vamos a otros
temas y es que con motivo de la
iniciativa octubre rosa una operación
destinada a concientizar y apoyar la
investigación en torno al cáncer de mama
médicos y voluntarios dan la voz de
alarma sobre el tratamiento tardío de
las pacientes debido a la pandemia
veamos una actualización sobre la
situación en el hospital en francia-
gustavus y la quinta mejor institución
de salud especializada en cáncer
neurología del mundo
no respire respiren cada dos años las
mujeres mayores de 50 años en francia
pueden participar en la detección del
cáncer de mama de forma gratuita rossi
link ha estado participando desde 2010
mi ginecólogo me dijo que hicieron una
mamografía así que lo hice y fue
entonces cuando me diagnosticaron este
fibroma es bueno saber hacia dónde vamos
qué podemos hacer y si no es demasiado
tarde el hospital gustave roussy es el
principal centro europeo de lucha contra
el cáncer allí descubrieron que la
mayoría de mujeres no se atrevían a ir a
consulta durante el confinamiento está
bien todo está bien como parte del
examen organizado hay un segundo
radiólogo que se asegurará de que no
falte nada este retraso a veces empeora
los diagnósticos la paciente esperó
medio año a causa del hobbit como se
expuso ella había comenzado a palpar una
hinchazón en un seno antes del periodo
encierro y no volvió sino hasta finales
de agosto
ahora tenemos una masa blanca si
comparamos con el lado en el que hay
tumor maligno de mama
el hecho de haber esperado seis meses
hizo que hoy sea de esta talla por eso
hoy el tratamiento es importante la
quimioterapia cirugía más radioterapia
pero es importante no acostumbrarse a
sentir algo que persiste que no se mueve
con el ciclo y que podría ser una lesión
sospechosa de la mama
cada año cerca de 12.000 mujeres en el
mundo mueren por cáncer de mama se
anunció el premio nobel de economía 2020
el galardón fue atribuido este lunes a
los estadounidenses por el milagro de 72
años y robert su elección de 83 los
expertos en la teoría de las subastas de
invenciones que desarrollaron nuevos
formatos que impactan desde la compra de
cuadros hasta la licitación de redes de
comunicación el premio será entregado el
10 de diciembre
las aves es la real academia sueca de
ciencias ha decidido hoy otorgar el
premio en ciencias económicas en memoria
de alfred nobel a paul armin y robert
wilson por las mejoras en la teoría de
las subastas y la invención de nuevos
formatos de subastas
finalizamos con el campeón de la nba y
es que lebron james ya tiene su cuarto
anillo los ángeles lakers ganaron el
sexto juego de las finales a los miami
heat y son los nuevos campeones de la
mejor liga de baloncesto o básquetbol
del mundo triunfo por 106 a 93 en un
partido que se quedó sin emoción ya en
el segundo cuarto culmina así con broche
de oro este proyecto casi personal con
el que consiguió darle a los lakers un
anillo lebron james una década después y
justo el mismo año en el que falleció
kobe bryant los aficionados tampoco se
han olvidado de la leyenda de la nba en
estas celebraciones que vemos por las
calles de los antes
[Música]
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía les recordamos las noticias no
se detienen con actualizaciones
constantes en nuestra señal televisiva e
información al momento en nuestro sitio
web france24 puntocom
[Música]